I have some new tour dates to announce
and some of these are coming up soon and
these are new
August 3rd Chattanooga Tennessee
Soldiers and Sailors Memorial auditoring
Auditorium
August 4th Memphis Tennessee the Canon
Center for the Performing Arts
September 7th Milwaukee
[Music]
September 13th San Jose
California the San Jose Civic Center
September 16th Oakland California the
Paramount Theater
October 5th Cleveland Ohio at Temple
live at Cleveland Masonic
and then October 7th Akron Ohio at E.J
Thomas Hall and October 19th Washington
D.C DAR Constitution Hall artist presale
begins Wednesday July 12th at 10 A.M
local time with code Rat King General on
sale begins Friday July 14th at 10 A.M
local time we've also added an eighth
show in Toronto on August 30th at the
Elgin Theater tickets for that are
available now get your tickets only at
theovan.com
t-o-u-r any other site is a secondary
site
man craziest thing um
you know I was eating dinner
you know because I
I eat at night
I'm not gonna lie to anybody I eat it I
eat it you know I eat in the evening I
eat at night
I I eat dinner you know I'm a
it's just kind of one of the people I am
I'm somebody that eats dinner
and
yeah I guess there's a new I don't know
if this is everywhere but this was um
they're going uh blood donor
they're looking for blood
um they came to the door the blood donor
people come to the door and ask if
anybody is willing to donate blood
and I'm like
you know I'm eating dinner
that was the thing I'm having dinner I
don't wanna
I guess I don't want to stop having
dinner to give to give I mean I want to
give blood I want to be supportive I
just think it's weird
if they're going door to door
trying to get it
I understand you go to door-to-door you
need a glass of milk
right
I understand you go door to door you
need
um
CPR you know hey Ernie can't breathe we
can't you know we need help
um
but door to door for blood that's a
I can even handle the insect guy hey
buddy we're here you know
you know that guy always shows up he's
like hey man we're just you know
we're doing we're Exterminating the
neighbors want to extend the option to
you
you know we'll give you forty dollars
off
and then he's always like what's that
behind you is that a wasp you know you
always they always try to scare you them
guys
like oh damn he'll just do like that
with his head and like oh
was that a what you know
and they're doing fake wasps
and some of these companies now these
insect companies they'll have a guy
sitting in the truck with a little drone
little
drone wasp
and he'll have that [__] going
and they set you up and then he's like
damn your house is infected
you know
you got bed bugs you got benchworms
foreign
you got damn you could have you know
there's probably bumblebees in your
flout and the you know
in your uh bread box and you're like
what you know but before you know it
that's eighty dollars and you got some
guy spraying gas all right you know
doing that gas all around the house or
the you know they come through and
they're just spraying
I mean those insect people they'll spray
damn
I saw a dude one time he was on his
phone he just had the gun the spray gun
just going
he left about probably seven or eight
ounces of uh
you know it's probably just repellent
he left seven or eight ounces in a
children's playroom I saw him just he
was only just setting on the gas he was
on his phone ordering something
getting him a Jimmy John or getting them
a
fat Sal's
you know or something
or a vet you know
getting him a little bit of Butch's
Pizza he was ordering something on the
phone
but um
yeah so those are people I can
understand doing door to door
those are people I can understand
foreign
but when they're door-to-door
like Hey we're here with the blood you
know
so and you know State blood bank or
something and we're here
we're just seeing if anybody in the
house in the home today is willing to
give blood and then the guy kind of
looks in my house like
like
he's gonna see somebody in a distance
who just happened and be like oh you
know I gotta I got extra blood on me or
whatever all right yeah you know I
wouldn't
I was just going to play some Call of
Duty but I'll drop off a pint I'll give
you half a pint
I um
I don't know if I can legally give blood
or not they said I couldn't one time
because I had done uh steroid use
and they won't let you give blood
so
it kind of hurt my feelings a little bit
but you know it shouldn't hurt my
feeling but when somebody's like hey we
don't want your blood that's a really
because you got a lot of blood
somebody's like damn we don't want your
blood
yeah door-to-door sale and that would be
going door to door
they don't have as much of it
you know when I was young the egg man
would come and he'd come and he'd bring
you know he'd show you a thing of eggs
you want some eggs you know
and my mom would be like get our get off
our porch you [__] pervert
because sometimes he'd be looking in the
windows sometimes he'd just be looking
at he wouldn't even have any eggs
he's like dude are you selling eggs or
are you just
a Peeping Tom you know like are you you
don't have any eggs
so what are you doing here
you know it's 10 P.M
and who what other Drive what other
people
they had door-to-door
um
oh the people would do the magazines and
it was like a scam you know
they come they'd be like dancing on your
porch like hey don't you want a copy of
this magazine you know
and it would be a scam they'd have like
a menu
of magazines even like Time Magazine you
know Newsweek Cosmopolitan
um [__] getting rowdy you're like
that's
and that was a cookbook they also had
like a little cookbook area
um
but I remember and it was always a scam
you'd pay the guy you would never see
the magazines
and then a year later they'd come back
by
the yeah some of the titles had on there
it was just they were like is this are
these really magazines you know
gays and guns and it was like is that a
that was a I remember they had
um all types of stuff in there Sports
Illustrated
um different stuff
grateful to be here with you guys today
um I know it's been a while since we had
a solo and I'm sorry about that
but uh it won't be any longer
let's get into it baby it's Bishop gun
[Music]
Cornerstone
oh but when I reach that ground I'll
share this piece of mine I found I can
feel it come on
little town
for me to sell that parking break and
let myself go mine
I'll sit and tell you my story
[Music]
and there they are right there that's
Bishop Gunn with shine gotta love them
so grateful for that song
that song has really giving us an Anthem
and a a piece of material over the years
to to have together
um
what's going on just staying alive
brother that's it
um uh it's been a bit I'm trying to
think of where to start
um I feel a little bit nervous actually
I think I don't know if I just haven't
done this in a while or
uh
yeah I don't know I feel a little
nervous I feel kind of nervous today
um
so that's okay I'm just going to say
that
you know and that's okay
um
yeah I want to just fill you in what's
going on with with with me recently just
tell you what I've been up to and uh
yeah see I feel like I'm just forgetting
how to do this but that's okay
I'm not it's just like a new it's just
been a little bit
um of doing a solo episode haven't done
it in a while and so I'm really grateful
I was really excited to be able to sit
here and I want to get into some calls
in a little bit
um
I just got back I went to UFC that was
really cool but one thing I did really
recently that was
that was just Divine and I mean you
could just God it was just dang divine
I mean you could feel the Lord just just
touching you while you were watching it
and it was the rodeo
I went to the rodeo recently I went to
the Franklin Rodeo and it was in
Franklin Tennessee and
um man the rodeo you think it's going to
be a p you know
a lot of people spit and dip and
and even women doing it you'll have a
woman she'll have it you know
she'll ever hit a Copenhagen tucked up
you know somebody's they're tough
they'll tuck they'll tuck a hitter Hagen
right up in their labia you know what
I'm saying they don't
you're like damn which where's she
spitting from you know and stuff so it
can be a unique lot out there but
or a unique lot of people that go to
watch Rodeo but it was unbelievably
entertaining
I had just
I've forgotten how good it was you know
I think I'd only been once and um
and I had pink eye so I couldn't even
see that good I remember I think my mom
took us once and um
and yeah so I was you know
only had you know my I was
I was infected at the time so I couldn't
see good but it was unbelievable I went
to the Franklin Rodeo and
at one point there's this event where
they bring out all of these they bring
children out of the stands and they they
tie like ribbons to
the the tale of
or they put like a ribbon onto the end
of a sheep and they let the sheep run
and all these kids just Chase these
sheep trying to get the ribbon off of
the tail it's just
it was insane and then you have also
bull riding
um
and then you have
there's some calf like roping and stuff
some of that's kind of intense if you
were kind of like very you know pretty
sensitive it can be maybe a little bit
intense but
yeah I mean you'll see they'll be lasso
and sometimes they'll
you'll see milk fly to something you
know you're like damn was that milk
and your dad's like cover your eyes
you're not supposed to be on this
website
um but they had a horse there's one
point where they TR some this man had
trained a horse
and the horse stands up on his legs
brother and I'd never seen this
and this horse I don't know if he was
like a business or like a business horse
or if he's one of the
you know if he
I don't know how he got his skill set
really
but he stood upon his legs like in the
middle of the arena and then he walked
out of the Arena
on his legs a horse
and I'd never seen it
but it blew my mind anyway if you get a
chance to go see a rodeo
um I totally recommend it I just I'd
forgotten how great it was how
interesting it was
um the different amounts of talent you
get to cheer for people
they got some hardcores out there too
I mean they got some women out they got
some
strong you know men and women
they got some people that are
real
they got some people that'll [__]
they'll shake your [__] hand
you know
they will shake your hand
so they have some people like that out
there um
but yeah it was amazing I just want to
recommend the rodeo if you haven't been
going and doing things that are
interesting or you're thinking oh
there's nothing in my area or if you
just haven't been to a rodeo in a long
time I want to recommend the rodeo
um
what else we had the uh we had the
Roseanne uh our Roseanne episode got
taken down do a little bit of business
with you guys here
um our Roseanne episode got taken down
uh and we got strikes on YouTube uh a
strike
on YouTube
and we couldn't post for a week those
were the rules
um and at first I was really shocked you
know I believe that I believe that what
Roseanne said was satire
right I believe that wholeheartedly I
believe that she is a comedian I know
she's a comedian we're having a
saturation we're having a conversation
she was being satirical to me very
evident
um
now YouTube has their own policies they
have hate speech policies and that's
what we got uh our strike for was hate
speech
um and I think I was I was kind of
offended by that
you know I thought I didn't think that
that was
um
I didn't think that it was fair
and I think the toughest part was
there's no communication you don't get
to communicate with YouTube really about
it
right they kind of this ruling comes
from like a place you can't or people
you can't communicate with or access and
then
um that's how they do it right
and now I understand they have their
policies and they have to do their best
to uphold their policies right and I'm
thankful to YouTube I'm very grateful
that it exists
right because I have a place to speak
from
um
you know I have a platform uh from which
to talk and and a place to host a show
like I'm very grateful for that
truly am
but yeah I think the tough part was just
that it felt like there was no
communication about it it was just like
this is what it is
and
and I understand that's their policies
but
I think there was
um there should be I feel like you
should have some conversation about it
because they call
for YouTube they call you like Partners
right you're like we're partners
you know
because I'm not an employee of YouTube
but I'm a partner that's what they they
call it you know that you're a partner
YouTube Partner
and so
yeah I just felt like if I'm a partner
then let's at least have a discussion
with me about what's going on
um
so you can hear what I'm you can hear
what I'm thinking and what I'm feeling
you know so I think that was the
toughest part I just felt like it was
kind of uh
uh I felt like there was no chance for
me to
speak
or share what I was thinking or feeling
and maybe that's just how it is you know
that's business
um so I don't know I had some different
feelings about it
um um
you know I also have to take into
account that I want to be able to have a
show I want to be able to connect with
people
and um
and just times are different
you know people could say well you can
still have your voice even if you lose a
Channel or you're
social media gets taken down you still
have your own voice
which is true
but times have changed you know it's
like
um it's not just a soap box in your
neighborhood anymore in your tribe you
know your people are communicating with
a lot more people at once
and on bigger levels
um or different levels
but when you communicate something out
in social media on YouTube it's
accessible to more people so it's not
like you're just standing on your
soapbox
you know in a town hall or something
um
so it's really like YouTube has kind of
become like paper like they're the paper
you know all these social media
platforms they're the paper now
and it's almost sometimes it feels like
well the paper
gets to determine what's written on it
whereas it used to feel more like hey
you can write what you want on this
paper
and deal with
people's and deal with consequences or
interpretations of it
but now as soon as it feels like well if
you
put something on this paper
the paper
is now determining what you're even
allowed to it's like as if a piece of
paper you're writing stuff on it and the
paper was able to
edit as you're writing
so I don't know if that makes any sense
but
it's just it you know it's just an
interesting time
now what was really crazy was that
when the episode got taken down I
believe that uh it should be able to
live somewhere right I believe that it
was a great episode I was really
grateful to
um be be able to talk with
you know a real Matrix matriarch yeah a
real matriarch of Comedy
you know she is
I mean
she there's nobody like Roseanne
you know and I know she's had a lot of
like things that have come at her over
the years a lot of
um you know she always makes controversy
she always does
um sometimes it seems like it's too much
for sure
uh other times it seems like
what you would expect out of a comedian
out of a
an instigator
you know it's kind of what you would
expect
um because that's what that's what
challenges comedians in the first place
like oh I can say this I can't say this
how do I
you know how do I Mill around this area
of taboo
right whatever the taboo is
um
but then so then I put the episode on to
Twitter
because they allow longer form episodes
now or longer video on there and then
Elon Musk
the freaking alien
liaison you know
he
he shared it
and so that went
I mean that was unbelievable that you
know just the fact that he did it you
know
um now and whatever you think about Elon
you know or whatever you you know that's
not it that that isn't that's not what
I'm thinking about I'm just thinking how
fat he was like a man who's like an
influential man
and he's sharing
you know me and Roseanne and I having a
conversation so
it was just pretty fascinating uh the
whole experience is kind of fascinating
you know I think I was bummed out
because I feel like I've done a lot of
like neat work on YouTube and I'll try
and show up every week for the channel
and
um
yeah so I think that's what that's what
it was like if we're Partners have a
discussion at least someone speak to me
um
but that's uh
that's there it's their it's their
platform
and those are that's how that's their
rules
and you know a lot of times we have to
play Within
um
the rules you know if I walk onto a
basketball court I I know
the rules you know and
that's the rules so
today's episode is brought to you by
betterhelp we're grateful for them we're
grateful for facilities that offer help
to people
if you are struggling feeling like
yourself shoot I am today
um then better help can be there for you
one thing that I love about betterhelp
is that you can FaceTime you can call
you can text with a therapist you can
um kind of like level it the way that it
works best for you
um if you're working with a therapist
and you don't feel comfortable with them
get a new therapist
you're not going to hurt anybody's
feelings
um but you want to try different ones
until you get one that you feel like is
helping you
um navigate some things
or that's my thought anyway that's just
my uh experience
um but better help
Nobody Does it as good as them it's
entirely online designed to be
convenient flexible and suited to your
schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist and switch therapist
any at any time for no additional charge
let therapy be your map with better help
visit betterhelp.com Theo today to get
10 off your first month that's better
h-e-l-p.com slash t h e o sometimes in
life we're faced with tough choices and
the path forward isn't always clear
better help can help profiling
surveillance data harvesting
there are lots of things not to like
about tech Giants but what can you
actually do about it when you rely on so
many other products it's a great
question
well the good news is it doesn't take
much for you to take a stand
for less than seven dollars per month
you can join me and fight back against
big Tech by using
expressvpn that's right
expressvpn helps you and anonymize
make Anonymous much of your online
presence by hiding your IP address
your IP address is a unique identifier
that every device has that allows big
Tech to match your activity back to you
that's why I use expressvpn on all my
devices
to make it much more difficult for them
to exploit my data for their own profits
and the best part is how easy it is to
use expressvpn
or the expressvpn app
I just tap one button on my phone or
computer to turn it on and that's all it
takes to keep people out of my business
so if you don't like big Tech tracking
you and selling your personal data for
profit it's time to fight back
expressvpn.com
Theo right now to protect your online
freedom and privacy that's
expressvpn.com
t-h-e-o
expressvpn.com Theo
what else God I don't know why I feel
nervous today man
I had a good time I got to go to Utah
and they they have a water shortage over
there
so if you got a bucket of water or
something you tell you man you get you
two buckets of water it'll get you'll
you'll get a date with a with the prom
queen over there
you know if you're appropriately aged
two buckets of water homie they'll do
you know if you're in southern Utah they
got a there's a drought
if you start crying somebody come up and
hold a plant right under you like hey
buddy I know you're depressed but
I got this Bougainvillea that needs some
help
um
yeah there's a drought and I thought it
was interesting like in this town uh we
did a show in Springdale Utah and it was
beautiful
I'd never done this it was like outdoors
and there was
um
you know just nature big chunks of
oh
what is it like a big
um
how do I do
a big chunk of nature
it's like where nature raises their hand
kind of mountains
they have huge mountains
and what is that mountain range
Southern Utah
and that mountain range is the Wasatch
Range I think
and it goes over there to um Mount Zion
Park and it's just stunning
but we had a show over there and my
brother lives in that area and they only
have so much water
and so
yeah I mean you gotta
you know you gotta you gotta ask for
help
um if you need water you you they don't
people don't have it
you know people just don't I mean you
sometimes I would find myself licking my
hands and then rubbing it in my eyes
so I could still blink like you get
dehydrated there pretty easily so
um they have like water shares it's
called in the area where
if you
move you can't build a new home there
unless you have water shares
and
um and that's like your allotment of
water
and my brother in the morning they go
and they turn they like Go in different
parts of their town and they have to
turn these different valves and then
they get their share of water
so it's pretty
like we went for a ride and we turned a
valve then we went to another part and
turned another one
and then went to another place and
and at that time you're like on
unleashing the water and then you get
back home and the water is just coming
down the street like in this little
um
like cement ravine
and you're getting like your allotment
of water for
the week or month I thought that was
pretty cool I've never seen it before
but the people are damn dehydrated there
you know you gotta you know they're
sharing water every ounce is accounted
for in that area you'll tell some of you
tell a neighbor hey can you flush your
toilet
because
we
we want to make some soup you know it's
just they don't have uh
they don't have a lot to go around so
what else do I want to talk to you guys
about
oh I went and did Kill Tony that was
amazing if you haven't seen kill Tony
it's unbelievable
I think it's unbelievable what they put
together there
it's uh
it's like the realest
I mean they have people that get up to
get up and do one minute of Comedy have
your name pulled out of a hat it's so
hard to do one minute is hard to do
because it's like
you can't really go into a story
so you kind of have to just tell a
couple jokes
um
but it's just so much pressure and then
it's crazy because the the performer
gets one minute and they know that's
what they get but then Tony gets 2 000
minutes if he wants to rip them to
shreds
um and they just have a beautiful band
there somebody is um blind
so that's on you know anytime you got a
blind guy that's a [__] crystal ball
right there
that's the original crystal ball do you
rub on a blind guy until he says
something
and if that you know
I mean that's that's dark magic baby
if you rub on a blind until they just
whatever they say and then that's
the original crystal ball right there
um but if you haven't seen kill Tony I
was just it just blew my mind how great
it was and what I just forget kind of
and it's just if you never watched it
you just have to watch it sometime
um
so
what else did I want to say went to
Tampa
had a couple good shows in Tampa one
night was a little tough I thought
same for Vegas one night was a little
tough
you know I think I've been feeling all I
feel I think what I'm realizing what I
feel I feel just feel a lot of pressure
today uh
and I know there's no pressure by you
guys it's just pressure by from my own
self I guess you know I just feel
um
as the podcast has gotten busier
uh I feel more
I guess I feel more
like a
um
like how do I do it that like that I
have to do it that I have to do it
perfectly
you know that's what I feel like
um
yeah I think I feel like since there's
more people that have been tuning in
that I have to do it perfectly
so and that's okay it's a normal
probably thing that people feel that way
um
yeah so I'm just taking you guys through
I guess some of my thoughts right now
but I you know I can't I I I I I can't
do it perfectly
you know I can't do it perfectly so I
can't I have to be careful not to leave
myself in that space where I'm
putting that much pressure on myself
um
yeah uh
so I'm just gonna do it you know to the
best of my ability that's what I'm gonna
do and I know it's easy for me to say
that but yeah for some reason I just
have a lot of that feeling like
I just have but I think that's that's
some of the nervousness
that that does have feel like this
feeling of just that I have to do this
perfectly
and that's
um
I don't know what that is but
it's uh it feels like a pressure
and I know nobody's putting that
pressure on me it's just in my own head
and some of that was probably natural
but I just wanted to speak that out loud
so um
just conscious of what
I'm feeling instead of just feeling
something and not trying to know what it
is
but let's get into some calls man we had
some that came in as always the hotline
is
[Music]
985-664-9503 the Baja
I've been working on that just even
turned down in the bar in the Baja soda
bajas in the Baja soda Minnesota yeah
and you want to know why
and you wanna know why
foreign
got this pug shirt on them keyed up boy
damn son
I'll I'll pee behind your cousin's house
dog with this shirt on
that's who I am bro
I'll run up and just start humping your
leg baby that's what happens homie
with this shirt on anything's possible
you can identify whatever you want
that's the thing
bro you could you know
you could Chase uh somebody's [__] uh
you could chase a squirrel
and nobody say nothing to you
that's the power of the Pug shirt
that's the power of the Pug shirt baby
um let's get into a couple calls here
this is golden Drake I'd like to talk to
you
because you're one of my favorite
comedians
thank you Garland Drac
um appreciate the call brother and thank
you for the nice words man let's hear
more my phone number is 270.
-55
[__] I remember my number man
270-89-893
[Music]
-270
[__]
five
eight nine three
two seven oh
[__]
ing well and then and uh hold on man
yeah that's and that's
there you go well
we tried our best Garland we tried our
best there brother
and thank you uh again for the nice
words and that's where that look that's
the age we live in now people don't
remember their phone number
um
what else we got here
[Music]
hey Theo uh recently I was at the
OB GYN the ladies doctor
um I recently miscarried and you know
you have to go for a couple appointments
afterward and I happen to have been
listening to your and stavros's uh
podcast
and the doctor overheard where you
prefer to call the ladies Parts uh
Cooter oh yeah
Cooter baby I know what you're saying
and that's
yeah cause cooter
you know you people know what it is but
you could also pretend hey it could be
something else you know oh man we were
we just saw a cooter run by here you
know
well look what is that a cooter you know
you can almost pretend oh damn
my cousin
you just got
attacked by a cooter
um yeah just there's I think you know
it's still enough of the masking where
you don't have to
you know say uh
you know what I'm talking about
so onward
instead of the other word that starts
with a P yeah and I just said it too I'm
gonna say it again real quick I'm gonna
pretend like I'm not saying it but
okay onward and
and she thought that it was
absolutely one of the funniest things
she had ever heard
and then she asked what you would prefer
to call the male equivalent and I
realized I didn't know
what you would prefer to call it that
deaf leopard homie that's what I call it
that Def Leppard baby
that skeet Pony you know what I'm saying
that bust knuckle
I think these are good terms for it
that sperm Randall they'll call us
sometimes
Daddy got that sperm Randall on him
um what else people call it the uh
that batter twig
somebody say let me break you off a
little something let me break you off
half a tablespoon out this batter twig
I would say wiener as well
you know
um
I think people say wiener
and I think weiner is good you can say
it near children
if you yell at somebody too suck my
weiner
it almost seems like oh this guy kind of
means it because everybody says SMD
right say hey man hey but if you say
hook my will
I think people are more into it what
else I watched that uh Joey Chestnut
that guy
that Frank that that [__] that dude
is a damn Frank pony huh
gosh and that dude just he's that real
boner homie
he'll throw them uh he'll just guzzle
them Franks God how many gay dudes
watch the
Nathan's
hot dog eating contest I mean it must be
it must be like the when people do those
Game of Thrones viewing parties there's
no way that in gay culture that isn't a
huge thing
that should be on Pay-per-view
at every gay club I feel like there's no
it would it should be the biggest
night at the gay club it's like the
Super Bowl it feels like
some dude right
yammering down 67 francs bro
that'll
I mean I don't if you I think if you are
gay and
around I think that will excite you
I would think so
um
so anyway just thinking out loud I don't
even know what I'm talking about but
yeah that's what I think I would call it
probably
and I think uh
I would call it probably uh wiener
that Cooter bridge too
because a lot of times if you're making
love to somebody and you look down your
your wiener just looks like a bridge
between you
and
cooter
you know you could if you if you even
had like little characters you could put
them on it
a hunting where you will go a hunting we
or you know I don't know what you could
do different music I guess but
but yeah Joey Chestnut damn he rumbled
down in French boy and then he's wet
he's just like his all it's all in his
shirt and chest there's how is that not
the gay Super Bowl
you have to prepare for your financial
future there's no doubt about it you
have to prepare for what you want your
future to look like if you want to save
you need to save
I'll tell you this a credit card
consolidation loan from lightstream can
help you pay off your credit cards and
lock in a low fixed interest rate
start at 8.99 APR with auto pay and
excellent credit
now I'll say this I've had some loans
that I Consolidated and worked out great
so I'm familiar with this process
from lightstream you can get a loan from
five thousand to one hundred thousand
and there are absolutely no fees you can
even get your money as soon as the day
you apply
and just for our listeners apply now to
get a special interest rate discount
and save even more the only way to get
this discount is to go to
lightstream.com
t-h-e-o that's
l-i-g-h-t-s-t-r-e-a-m.com slash Theo
subject's credit approval rates range
from 8.99 APR to 25.49 APR and include
0.50 auto pay discount lowest rate
requires excellent credit terms and
conditions apply and offers are subject
to change without notice visit
lightstream.com
Theo for more information
are you aware that 35 of all fatal
accidents occur between 6 pm and
midnight
um that people aged 25 to 34 of the
highest amount of drivers involved in
car crashes
and that people aged 15 to 24 had the
highest rate of emergency room visits
due to car accidents of all age groups
that's information folks
if you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan that's right
Morgan and Morgan is America's largest
injury Law Firm they have over 100
offices Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
for clients Morgan and Morgan has a
proven track record of fighting to get
you full and fair compensation
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is as easy as trying to find a hairless
cat in a nudist colony
yeah
you know what I'm talking about boy
that's right submitting an injury claim
with Morgan and Morgan is so easy if
you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless they win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com
this past weekend or dial pound law
pound 529 from your cell phone that's
for the people.com
this past weekend or dial pound law
pound 529 from your cell this is a paid
advertisement
all right let's get to another call
um
this episode's a little all over the
place guys uh I want to thank everybody
that's come out recently and seen me
um dude it's just been unreal
you know and it feels I think
it feels tough to repay people for the
support
that's I think sometimes what feels a
little bit tough it's like man
how will I be able to be as supportive
to this person
you know
how how can I be as supportive to you
who has been who's being supportive to
me
um
so it's okay it's just in my heart I
think some of it'll get figured out over
time
[Music]
uh but yeah I think about that though
and I'm just yeah I'm just thankful that
you guys have been coming out
all types of people damn Chicanos
americanos uh
Black Folk we've had uh Chinese
um
um we've had
you know kind of uh
you know what I'm talking about
um
Filipinos
we've had everybody
all types have come out and we're just
grateful for everyone so thank you guys
so much and women too
and this has been beautiful a lot of
beautiful ladies come out too and Men
let's see what else we got here
hey Theo this is Jacob price from South
Bend Indiana uh I know on your podcast
you talk a lot about you know what you
like about certain girls you know South
Bend and I've been over there to
Mishawaka as well
and I got uh
stuck in a
uh I got stuck in a townhouse with a man
who was
um chain smoking cigars
and I got stuck in there for a couple
days with him let's hear more
they talk about what we like in girls
but I was just curious uh what some of
your turn offs are uh you know something
oh yeah turn offs brother I feel it and
I would say probably chatty
if somebody's
just being too chatty why are they doing
it
don't do it
um orange perfume if somebody's wearing
orange perfume
I don't like it I don't like it I don't
like it that much senior citizen perfume
a lot of some of those have younger
women wearing senior citizen perfume I
don't understand that you can wear it
when you get there you know
um
I prefer if a woman doesn't work or know
the value will work I'm out I like a
hard-working woman
um
now she don't have to have three jobs
but I like a woman who just knows the
value of work
um
what else
oh turn off for me can't swim
if you can't swim honey
I mean the Earth is 80 water
so
if there's you know if there's a tsunami
and you trying to get on my back bye
[__] I'm doing me
you know what I'm saying I you know
I ain't your floaty
I ain't nobody floaty
so yeah if she can't swim I'm out
and what else
oh if she has way too many dietary
restrictions
I'm out
I'd love to discuss it more but no I
wouldn't I'm out I'm upstairs
so I think those are some of the things
that I really like and um
that
that are some of my things about women
you know and if women if a woman hate
butterscotches if you hate
butterscotch's baby
then I'm out
cause I love them I love a damn Beast
gosh for Daddy
let's take another call here
hey man my name is Angel bro and I
wanted to ask you something what do you
think about Colombians
oh yeah
well they're beautiful I mean most of
them are beautiful when um and all of
them are
you know
um
I couldn't you know I I believe in
Colombians
you know I couldn't do it
I couldn't do it so when I see him I see
you know I couldn't do it brother
Colombia
um
boy I'd be upstairs in a one-story house
homie that's how geeked up on that
hey you've been doing cooking
God damn
dude I'd snort everything in that damn
Country Boy
they call me baby Dyson I'll be out
there [__]
dude I'll do one 70th of an eight ball
out of somebody's out of a big girl's
belly button homie
that's who I am
I'm upstairs
yeah that's the thing I couldn't have
survived there so when I see a Colombian
you know
I re respectado
respectado
because I couldn't have done it man
for my I would have got an eight ball
for my 12th birthday
yes I wouldn't even have blown out the
can I would have just done blow I
wouldn't I would not have blown out the
candles oh but it just they Delight all
the candles I'd be doing you know
I'll be off doing gramming out I'm like
damn the Cake's burning
I'd be like my brain is burning
so there's a lot of me that's you know
that I would that that that that
so I commend them when I see them it's
just like damn how'd you do it I mean
I'd have been so coked up I'd have
turned 13 in a week
you give me eight ball for my 12th
birthday homie I'll be 13 in a week
so I just know that I would not have
been able to stay alive
you know I grew up running a lot of
sugar cane
and I I did enough of that
so if I was by that
that snow came baby
I'll be a sharecropper son
well we can do something called kind of
I will do it uh
so yeah I just couldn't have done it but
I believe in Colombians and I command
them and they should if they even make
it to 18 I think they should be they
should get a free house or free truck
small truck
but that's just what I think thank you
for calling and asking me and caring
about what I think is very sweet of you
let's see what else we got here
listening to your podcast with Adam
yeah thank you that was an episode with
Adam DeVine who was just in and man I I
uh I started the movie Outlaws and it's
good it's funny it's
um I'm looking forward to watching the
rest of it he is really funny
man I didn't I knew Adam was funny he's
always been very entertaining I I just I
I'm glad I I'm getting to see him again
um
yeah he is just he's really uh he's uh
he's extremely unique onward
y'all brought up the topic
similar story to that
uh this lady you know when we're 13 she
used to buy a beer and [__] you know she
was she was behind like 28 30 years old
and we all thought it was cool but uh
she also worked at a cafe in town and
they sold really good chicken strips but
uh oh yeah
yeah man and meeting an older woman is
very easy there's something very erotic
about it when you're a child
or when you're a teenager or something
or something
if you haven't you know once you start
getting
sexual interest
once you start looking through your
wiener as that third eye
you know you start seeing the world
differently
and you really do so yeah I could
imagine if there was a woman who you
felt a connection to
and that she also had
um chicken strips or another good
appetizer that that would be very
uh temptational let's hear more
when we she said get us food and
and you know she'd take us to her house
or something and we'd bang her out or oh
okay whoa surprise right there I didn't
he really
that took a turn in the thing onward
you know get nasty
anyway uh I lost my virginity to her for
some free chicken strips in the cafe
bathroom
and uh oh yeah
oh yeah buddy well there's something
beautiful about making love at work
there's something dangerous too about it
risque
you know especially if they had uh
uh chicken strips man there's something
very
avant-garde
uh about making love near a deep fryer
an active deep fryer
you know because you know if you're
doing sex things can get
you know there can be level changes
there's you know so
if you're in a if you're near an active
deep fryer that [__] you get one one
you have one paw that slips off into
that thing
you know you you're playing catch for
the dang uh
apple fritter after that you know you're
gonna be living with the damn bear claw
on you
so I think there's different ways to do
it then you know you're going to be
doing the pledge of allegiance with the
damn funnel cake over your for a for a
for a hand
so that's a thing you could end up real
damaged now I'd say this if you fried
your hand this would be the craziest
thing I bet
if you flash fried your hand you're
doing you're in the kitchen
your hand slips in there
how hard would it not be the first thing
to just bite into it
thank you for the call Brother
appreciate you and I hope we could offer
you a little bit of thought there
but
um
[Music]
dude I got to see Mel Gibson at the UFC
man I was so excited
I feel bad sometimes sharing about stuff
like that because I feel like it makes
me like
seem like I'm like a fancy guy you know
um
or like that I'm name dropping but it
was just fun like it just
yeah dude I can't believe that I got to
go again
and yeah it was just
I mean it was wild dude Mark Maguire was
there
um
and I love him
um no Mark Wahlberg
sorry uh
uh yeah and then
Mel Gibson dude Mel Gibson
from the Patriot brother aim small Miss
small
God he was there
and I want to see that new documentary
that came out
um
that everybody's been talking about so
we'll see if I can get to view that uh
let's take a couple more calls thank you
guys as always
985-664-9503 I'm gonna try to do another
solo episode soon I'm feeling a little
bit more settled I feel very uh
like I don't know frenetic today or
frenetic
um so I'm not trying to complain I'm
just trying to share with how I'm
feeling and sometimes it's like I can't
even I don't know I'm having trouble
even knowing how I'm feeling today this
just feels uh
well [__] it's [__] Monday so what
are you gonna do even
um
hey the uh uh I have a question for you
I didn't know what you would do uh me
and my wife tried out a threesome with
another girl and turns out she likes
girls now
and then we tried a threesome with
another dude and it turns out I kind of
like dudes so we're thinking about going
our separate ways
what would you do
well
y'all gay bro
you know and that's
that's great man you know that you're
gay
that's because the craziest thing is
when people don't know
when people don't know they gay
they they find themselves doing stuff
and wondering why they're doing it
they'll go lay on top of a man or
something for a few minutes and like
what the [__] are they and they but they
don't know it
you know sometimes people don't know
they're gay
and so at least you guys have figured
out I believe there's a lot of
um
kind of uh
I don't know if I want to say incoherent
gays out there but people that are gay
that do not know
they are gay
they're almost like ghosts
like ghost gays or whatever but I think
more incoherent gays because they are
gay but they do not know it
you know
you have a man you put you'll put him in
a wiener shed or whatever he'll sit in
there for four [__] hours
but then he'll come out talking about
his uh wife but he didn't he didn't he
ain't thinking hey why I've been in
there for four hours
in that wiener said boy that's gay and
boy
so congrats you uh gations
congratulations brother I'm happy for
you guys
um
what else my buddy Ernest fell off the
stage I don't know if you saw this it's
a great Tick Tock uh it was Morgan
Wallen Nelly Ernest there was a show
and Ernest tried to throw this Rose they
have a beautiful song called flower
shops
um
and he tried to throw a rose like as I
guess as far as anybody's ever thrown a
rose before
and uh
and he just you know he put hey he put
it all into it he used to pitch at
Lipscomb
he used to pitch at Lipscomb and uh
this one was a little outside
uh what else do we got let's let's take
one or two more calls from you guys man
um you can always hit the hotline
985-664-9503 let me know what's going on
with you
um
some exciting guests that we have coming
up
uh a lot of excitement in the air so
hello folks Larry in Upstate New York
um what's up Larry
just listening to the most recent
broadcast
[Music]
and you guys are talking about Guinness
book records and did Tom ever want to
have like a thing where he could do the
set of Records and it's funny you're
talking about this because I happen to
have thought about that and my thing I
would like to do is the longest P the
the longest urine taken steadily
straight constant stream longest time
they may already have somebody in there
well yeah look I think that's a
beautiful suggestion doing the longest
pee is beautiful
for Tom Segura and
um
and Bert Kreischer what would be a good
Guinness record for them
maybe longest sandwich
you know seeing both of them started the
opposite end of a different sandwich and
eat their way as far as they could
and try to meet in the middle
or just eat a long sandwich together the
other sorry the first way it sounds a
little bit yeah
but uh just eat it yeah just eat a eat
eat the world's longest sandwich the
longest two men have ever stood bare
chested pressing their chests against
each other
I could see them doing that
um what else could I see Tom and Bert
doing for a Guinness record
um
maybe the longest sentence
you know Bert can get into some long
sentences so maybe if he started a sense
and just tried to go as far as anybody's
ever gone
but also making sure that the sentence
makes sense so that would be
really really interesting
um what else
that's a good one I'd love to throw that
out to you guys what would be some
really neat Guinness Records to try and
set some rare ones I think the longest
maybe if you filled uh
if you fill your mouth with lump crab
meat
and ran
like ran like did you know
whoever could run the farthest with a
mouthful of
um LCM baby lump crab meat
I think that would be quite a work of
art
um yeah but those are some nice thoughts
man good to think out loud and be having
my brain work that makes me feel good
when my brain is
um active
made me feel warm
let's take this call right here here we
go
what's up here this is Zach bro
um right here at work right now brother
just uh I'm a Superman that's what I do
with y'all I clean the sewers they oh
yeah brother you're a Ninja Turtle baby
you down there and then pipes homie
so uh thank you very much for the call
let's hear more
get in there get in there and clean up
baby
but uh
we just um
tomorrow's uh the anniversary of my
father he uh you know he recently passed
away about two years ago
and uh
accomplished a lot you know in the time
that he's gone and
it's been a little rough because uh you
know he hasn't really uh I didn't really
get a chance to show him
um everything you know that I've been
able to accomplish you know
um but
just put a little down about Bill and uh
you know I uh I know you've been through
similar struggles with I didn't really
know my father I knew him I knew him
well but not well enough you know
um so
I just want to know if you have any
advice about that deal
just feeling a little down about my
props that's all but uh appreciate you
man gang baby thank you for the call
um
yeah man he
he's so proud of you
man he's so proud of you
and I'm sorry that he's not here with
you anymore
um
you know there's
I think about this a lot I think about
that your heartbeat like if you want to
feel your father you can put your heart
you can put your hand on your heartbeat
because he made that beat he and your
mother
they remixed a human that's how that
that's how it works
they they cut a track and that was you
but your heartbeat is it's their heart
beats
so that's the that's your that's the
drum of your father
he's it's he's in you
you know I can put my the I can put my
hand on my heart and I can feel
a beat that my father started that his
father started it's such
that's why when I think we have those
feelings of pile of being feeling like
you know that our parents are proud of
us or
um
that feeling of Pride goes so you can
feel how deep it is
I mean it'll bring tears to your eyes
sometimes
you know as a young man if you you know
sometimes especially you ask yourself
like is my is my father proud of me man
that's the that is the
there's nothing sharper than that edge
in a man
even the craziest thing is even if you
didn't even know your father
you know I can relate I didn't have
enough moments with my father that would
help us know each other well enough as
humans and as men I had some experiences
but I didn't have as many conversations
and like um
intimate connections you know or
sentimental connections because he was
passing away as I was just coming into
my teenagers years and stuff so I can
just relate I can just relate in that
sense
um
and it's crazy that you just want your
dad to be proud of you
there's nothing else a guy wants
it's like yeah I bear I you know I know
my father some but not a lot
but all I just that question will hit me
sometimes man I just hope he was proud
of me
so I just want to tell you that your
dad's real proud of you bro and uh
yeah and he put that beat in you man
that's his heartbeat
so if you want to feel your dad you want
to feel his that's his sound that sound
started with him
I mean you just a sample track homie
we all are
but I know he's proud of you man
um
and I'm sorry that he's gone but he's
living he's through you
when you smile he smiles
that's his smiles
when you see something beautiful he sees
Something Beautiful
and when you do good
and probably even when you don't man
he's he's proud of you
um
so just keep your head up on me and know
that you're not alone you know and other
way you can get uh you can live
vicariously and we like
you know when you interact with a mentor
a male mentor of yours
um and you let them know hey I really
appreciate this I appreciate uh your
outlooks and your thoughts you know if
you do
um that's a way to get a little bit of
fatherhood from someone else
um it's interesting it's like
you know maybe if you see a young man
and he's trying to do something for his
father but he can't do it or he can't
afford it or he can't help if you step
in there and help that's you doing
something for a father
and it may not be your father but you
are doing something for that position of
of a father
you are being of assistance to a father
and I notice that sometimes it helps me
some
you know it helps me uh
you know my father was real old so if I
do something nice for an old man an
older man it
it's
um or if I do something nice for a
friend's father it's it's in a way it's
me doing something nice for my own
father
you know I'm just it's like a um
I want to say example but there's a
better term for it
um so you can have your relationship
vicariously you can have that those
needs fulfilled somewhat a little bit
vicariously through other uh people's
relationships and father-son
relationships I find anyway
you know I have moments where I'll tell
some of my friends fathers who've had
importance in my life I'll say to them
hey I want to thank you you know like um
you know some of what I needed I was
missing but you showed up there
and um and that's not a knock to my
father
because my father I'm just I'm really
saying it's kind of like I'm using
someone else as a um
as like a template or as a mannequin for
my own father
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
but yeah isn't it so deep how it's so in
it's like all a man all the young man
wants is for his father to be proud of
him
you know it's unbelievable
it's unbelievable what a want that is
maybe if we taught more in schools from
that perspective
instead of from a knowledge perspective
what if we taught more from like an
emotional need perspective
like what if that you know how many of
your like what if a class for a young
men was how many of you want your father
to be proud of you you know
and then you taught from there
these are ways in the world where you
can create
um
where you can uh fulfill that need
anyway
uh thank you for calling brother and I
love you man and I appreciate you and
I'm proud of you too dude I really am
I really am man
um
uh yeah what else we got some great new
tour dates that we mentioned in the
beginning a lot of new cities so if you
get a chance
um looking forward to seeing you guys
there
uh I'm trying to think of anything else
that's been going on I don't know
I'm just trying my best today it's one
of those days you know I uh I prepared
some today to be prepared and it's just
um
you know you do the best you can and so
that's what we're doing
um I want to thank so many people for
being a part of my journey and being a
part of this uh podcast
um
yeah
man I'm trying just I'm just I'm having
a tough time today a little bit it's
okay I'm fine I just wanna you know it
is what it is
um I love you guys
um
will go in the way that we came out
uh I hope to do another solo episode
soon
I'll do a better job of not making it so
long between them
and um
yeah
I appreciate you and thank you guys met
so many nice people that have come out
over the to the over the past few months
to the shows
um
it's just it's hard to process uh at all
sometimes
and feel like you're showing enough
gratitude at the same time so
um that's some of the journey that I'm
in right now and um
yeah
that's what's going on over here
um I'll see you guys in Edmonton this
week and then up through the Northeast
we have shows next week and
um
yes thank you thank you guys for
supporting me uh sometimes when you
agree with me or sometimes when you
don't
um
you know that's something I'm learning
to do better in my life is uh be there
for people whether sometimes I agree
with some of their things or don't
you know
um so
I'm just grateful and I hope that I can
um
be as supportive to you in my life as
you are to me
you guys be good to yourselves baby you
deserve it
gang baby
foreign
[Music]
for me to sell that parking break and
let myself unwind
come on baby
swim and tell you my stories
[Music]
[Applause]